(audience clapping)
- The last time you were
here, what was it to promote?
Oh, the album!
- Yes.
- Okay, now you're touring
and your daughter is
touring with you.
How old is she?
- Yeah, she's two and a half,
and yeah, she's adorable.
- Probably got her own place
by now living on her own.
They grow up so quickly.
- I know, these past
few years have felt like
18 years at this point.
So, no, she's adorable.
She, it's, I don't quite know how
to pull off touring on a bus.
I, she's pretty fearless,
but I think things that
move without her control,
that's like not her favorite thing.
So I'm hoping she'll like, you know,
sleep in the bed with me and be okay.
- Is it like, mommy why
does the house keep moving?
- Probably.
- Do we owe money?
Why do we keep moving?
Now, speaking of families,
I heard yours is very competitive.
Is that fair to say?
- Yes.
Uh, yes, I think it's pretty fair.
We play games like Pinochle.
I don't know if you've played Pinochle.
- Pinochle, yeah that's
like a old people game.
(voices overlap)
- I'd love to learn, I
think it needs a comeback.
That's what that sounds like.
- We have like, great
grandparents would play
with grandparents, with parents.
So everybody kind of gets
around this one table
and it gets, you know,
like really intense.
- So great grandparents
play with grandparents,
play with parents,
so it's all old people.
- Yes, yes.
- There's nobody under 80,
apparently in this game.
- Pretty much.
And there was, I mean, we had like, even a
like a boxing bell installed
above the table where you play.
So, as you hit like a
really high bid, "Ding!".
Or if you win "Ding!".
- So in case anybody sleeping
that'll wake them up.
- Yes, yes, yeah.
No, the things that are screamed
at the table, no one's sleeping.
- Is that what this video was?
Is this your Dad ringing the bell?
Let's take a look.
(bell ringing)
- Adorable.
That's amazing!
- Well, he's waiting for the
game to begin apparently.
Now, you took your family on a trip
when you were young, that affected you.
Tell me about that.
Where, did you go?
- Uh, yeah we, 'cause I mean,
we've been trying to take Lou
on as many trips as we can.
- Right.
- But I remember it meant a lot to me,
fourth grade,
we went to Washington DC.
- Right.
- And we saw The Supreme Court.
- And I remember just being so awestruck
that in fourth grade I
decided I would become
a Supreme Court Justice.
- And how'd that work out?
- I know, right?
I feel like I just saw
you getting asked this.
- Same, as a Paleontologist.
- And I mean, I think it's
worked out in the sense
that now I really appreciate that,
you know, as humans we're not perfect.
As a country, we're not perfect.
But I think we all agree
that we want to be as good
as we can be, and we're striving for this.
And I think it, you know, it plays out.
I work in the music business,
which has some room to grow, I would say.
- And, and two and a half is perfect,
for The Supreme Court, for a child.
- Yeah.
- Really, all the
excitement, and the glamour,
and the glitz of The Supreme Court.
- Yeah, right?
The black robes.
- Oyez is fun, its fun to
hear Oyez all the time, right?
Yeah, yeah, it gives me
like a, I don't know,
I get chills still when I
hear like, "Oyez, oyez!".
You're like "Ahhh!".
- There you go.
Now, talent show American Anthems.
It also tries to bring out
some truths in America.
Isn't that correct?
- Yeah. So it's okay, so,
the concept is that every show
you get to meet an American Hero,
and
us as singer songwriters
get to meet them and then write a song.
They don't know it's happening,
but we get to meet them,
understand their story,
and write a song for them.
- Okay.
- Which is like, as a songwriter
you're used to digging deep
and finding the emotions.
- Right.
- But to do it so personally, I mean
you're used to this in your job
looking someone in the
eye and talking to them.
- But I make fun of them.
You meet a hero.
- I'm doing a very, you know,
emotional, heartfelt, I want you to know.
And I mean, this is how I
felt meeting Meredith the fact
that she, most people see
something and they go,
"Gosh that could be better.
I'm not going to do anything about it."
And Meredith said, "I'm
going to put the time
in and change kids' lives
and reach out to people."
It restored my faith, to
be honest in humanity.
'Cause she reached out to
people, anonymous people.
(audience clapping)
Yeah.
- So what was it she did?
- So, there's an
organization called Book'em,
that already collects books
to give to kids that need them.
To schools, organizations,
and she noticed, because you know,
as a Black woman, and
as a young Black child,
she knows she didn't have, you know
characters that looked
like her in the book.
So she would take brown
crayon and draw herself in.
- Right.
And now as an, as an
adult, she looked at this,
and she's like, you know, my
kids, I want them to have this.
I want these kids that are
getting these books to have this.
So she reached out, just
and kind of put it online
and to family and friends and said,
"Do you guys have any books you know,
with Black characters in
them, will you donate?"
And she just got this
overwhelming response,
of books.
And I mean, these are the stories
that you really want to
be hearing right now.
People really do care.
- Yeah.
- And she made sure that happened.
And these books are getting
to these kids, and just
meeting her, meeting
the people around her.
The song came out, it was
"Make Tomorrow Come Today".
'Cause I feel like
that's what she's doing.
- Well, great title.
- Thank you.
(audience clapping)
- Well I'm anxious to hear the song.
Will we hear it this Friday?
- On the show, yes we will.
- We'll hear it this Friday, okay.
American Anthems premieres
this Friday on PBS.
Go online now for tickets to
Cam's "The Otherside Tour".